it's ironic that we're here in
Montgomery Alabama still trying to
figure out ways to make sure that people
gain control over their lives the parent
choice movement is one part of that
overall effort well I think what's
important it's for low income and
working class people no matter what race
they are to be able to have these
choices that those of us would money
have it's particularly important for low
income and working class children of
color because so many of them are in
schools that do not work for them and so
the idea is to give them other options
of the choices if you're a low-income
working class family and you are
assigned to a neighbor school where 85
to 90 percent of the kids are failing
what do you do there is a shortfall and
there are some inequities in terms of
educational opportunities and access to
educational opportunities Black Power
was about how do people gain control
over their own institutions and over
their own lives what parent choice is
just trying to give families more
control over the decision-making as to
where is the best place for their
children to get the education that they
desire for them the biggest roadblocks
to education reform the biggest
roadblocks to school choices is some of
the folks who are part of the
intractable bureaucracy the status quo
the Union the Union politics teachers
care about kids most teachers but the
political arm of the teachers union is
about power and money and control well
the teachers union are protecting their
interests and so when we march today
past the Alabama Education Association
there's thousands of kids who are saying
we want choice you got a group of adult
standard over here saying no we want to
protect our interests
icon of is clear anytime you try to make
a change there's going to be holders of
the status quo we're going to oppose
that challenge we've been trying to
build a reform movement from the top
down but now particularly through school
choice week we're seeing it percolate
from the bottom up and that's why
through a recent poll we did at the
American Federation of children it
showed the seventy percent of all
americans believe in school choice so I
think people were sick and tired of
being sick and tired if you're part of
an organization and you have no power to
exit your voice is diminished but if
you're a part of an organization and you
have the capacity to exit it increases
your power and increases your voice so
that for example people who say well
these children are leaving our system
there's a clear way for the kids not to
leave improve the education that they're
getting and if you improve the education
that they're getting why would parents
want to exit this is something we've got
to take a stand on and we can't be held
hostage by the period politics of the
Union